absorbing all of that seeing the
monsters what was it like for you
it was exciting as hell well we've never
seen it was our first time seeing the
movie I know that I did ADR and they had
kind of like partial stuff done but to
kind of experience it in a big theatre
with an audience and seeing those
monsters do their thing it was also in
the film Malin Akerman is the one
responsible for the monsters wreaking
havoc on the city we've created the next
chapter in natural selection project
rampage works and your hair my hair it's
so much fun to change up your look to
get into character you know cuz it's so
far away from who I actually yeah right
yes totally not like you at all it
always helps to you know shift you into
evil mode but not everyone is evil as
Naomi Harris teams up with Duane to put
a stop to the rampaging animals you're
seeing in the helicopter and the plane I
was like I felt nauseous actually I'm
everything you were going through so
what was it like for you doing that it's
absolutely terrifying because they
simulated it like a real fool so they're
really tilting us and so those screams
are real that actually Naomi screams not
Kate screams at all I was really scared
talk about a bender I just found out
that you actually delivered both of your
babies or helped deliver both of your
liver go home we're kidding
yeah well I mean not here so my wife my
wife is a hero I just did this part but
yeah no no we were at a hospital in case
something goes crazy but I did the work
and then with the doctor looking over my
shoulder
Duane's having a baby soon maybe you
could do that nah we just we're talking
about it's pretty cool
[Laughter]